you understand guys we usually like deep
dive about all these movies individually
so we're trying to sum this all up in
like one minute of why it's here on the
list
comprehensive but quick
[Music]
what's happening there reject nation it
is the end of the year and we just
cannot end the year without doing this
video we are going to rank our personal
favorite of the spider-man live-action
films specifically the ones with toby
mcguire tom holland and andrew garfield
i know some people are putting venom on
their list honestly i feel like if you
told someone who doesn't know venom that
it's a spider-man movie and you said
it's a spider-man movie then they watch
it they'd be like you're a freaking liar
there's no spider-man in here
the spider-man lore because honestly i i
feel like if you take like civil war and
infinity war that's more spider-man
movie than freaking the venom movies are
and no one's putting those on those
lists i did contemplate what they're not
doing into the spider-verse but then
ultimately it was like now let's just
stick with the ones i think people
really want to hear the ranking for
which is the ones obviously spoiler
alert the ones that are in spider-man no
way home so yeah if you guys go ahead
leave a like would really appreciate
that tell us in the comments what your
personal ranking is and like i said this
is personal ranking i would like to be
here and say it's subjective you know so
people will disagree with what i got to
say what john's got to say but that's
boring this is pure objectivity you know
what if you don't have the same ranking
as us something's wrong with you that's
what i'm going to say and if our
rankings are different they're both
correct that's what i'm telling you guys
all right guys let's kick it off there
are eight movies here john has his
written down i don't have mine written
down i know pretty well off the dome we
re-watched them leading into no way home
it's funny because most of my
ranking really changed a lot upon
re-watching it but for number eight out
of the eight films my number eight would
have to be spider-man 3. uh i really
enjoyed spider-man 3 a lot i used to
like it a lot more when i was younger
but then re-watching it it's like i like
you know sandman he's cool some of the
action's all right but honestly i just
could not emotionally care about like
anything that was going on and never
once pulled anything out of me is it the
most memeable one sure you'll get your
rent when you fix this damn door even
the fun really starts to weigh down in
the last half hour that film once uh you
know topher grace gets the symbiote i
just start checking out and it happens
every single time and it honestly
watching it back to back from spider-man
2 to spider-man 3. the disappointment
factor just hits that much harder so
yeah at the bottom of my list would have
to be spider-man 3. this is going to be
so much fun number eight for me
uh drum roll is spider-man far from home
you know i re-watching both of the tom
hall movies in preparation i was very
torn this list for me has changed every
day since i've thought about it and why
this one lands at the bottom is mostly
because yeah there's a lot of fun to be
had there's a lot of you know enjoyable
humor there are a lot of enjoyable
action set pieces and whatnot a lot of
ways i think they're fine like they're
really enjoyable they're uh very shiny
and polished and this one obviously has
a lot to appreciate with mysterio and
whatnot but for the most part i feel
like this movie is about peter parker
trying to exist in another movie while a
different movie forces itself upon him
while there are some really dazzling
sequences such as the mysterio sequence
ultimately it's just not the one i would
want to return to before a bunch of the
other ones and even though yeah there's
some fun to be had it feels way more
like an avengers movie or it wants to be
an avengers movie it's about so many
other things that affect peter parker
but don't really feel like they're his
story definitively to me so that's why
far from homes at the bottom well number
seven for me would be far from home
i do agree with all these sentiments
it's funny because i feel like
everything from one through seven i
actually would say i overall like like
every movie here that's the part of the
powerful thing about the franchise of
spider-man is that for the most part i'm
like even the ones at the towards the
bottom of the list i would actually say
i do like those movies far from home in
particular i would echo exactly
everything that you said and while i
feel like no way home retroactively
makes the homecoming and far from home
better films when you realize like oh
they're actually kind of doing a bit of
an origin tale i feel like it's a little
too much at odds with itself especially
uh with a lot of the decision making
that peter parker is doing i think a lot
of tension gets sacrificed for comedy
there's something about the the first
two tom holland movies where i just uh i
i don't really feel much of an emotional
investment until towards the end of
those films
so while fun while fine while passable i
don't really bind to the stakes to weigh
later on i think peter like an mj's left
field even at this point in peter's life
i have difficulty subscribing to the
idea that he doesn't really want to help
save the world from an elemental that
he's been told can destroy the world but
instead just be on his field trip comes
a little too much iron man junior for my
personal taste and there's a lot of
comment that doesn't quite hit for me in
spite of the fact that i think both tom
holland and jake gyllenhaal give great
performances and how funny i think ned
is it mainly just leaves me feeling like
it's cute i still like the movie it's
just not one of my faves yeah absolutely
and moving on to number seven it's
homecoming for me and for similar
reasons i i like it better than far from
home because it is a bit more focused
and it is charming to have this sort of
ferris bueller take on peter parker
bringing him into the mcu but a big part
of it for me is i like tom holland a lot
in this movie in both of those movies in
no way home as much as we don't need the
origin story there's not enough else
around him to endear me beyond just
being like yeah i like this guy he's
he's doing good i i think he's a good
choice and yet the material isn't really
making him sing it's not moving me there
are a lot of good and bad in the
spider-man franchise and often
oscillating in the same movie and i feel
like this one for me is pretty pleasant
throughout my favorite thing about it is
michael keaton he is the thing that
moves the needle most and everything
else is pleasant and likable and
arguably probably objectively better
than some of the things that i will list
after it but as an emotional experience
i'm just not that compelled when i think
i want to put on a spider-man movie to
go watch homecoming yeah yeah my number
six is homecoming
with homecoming in particular on this
rewatch it's weird when i look back at
when this movie first came out i was
just so excited at the prospect of
spider-man being in the marvel cinematic
universe but every single time i've
re-watched it i've liked it less and
less i do have a hard time dealing with
the fact that it pretty much feels like
there's something that solves peter his
problems all the time whether it be
peter parker or spider-man he somehow he
gets out of the consequences there's way
too much tech i feel like that's kind of
the point like i said we're far from
home this movie gets really interesting
towards the end when michael keaton does
come face to face with tom holland you
know before the homecoming dance that's
when the movie finally gets a little bit
of tension and starts feeling like
there's some actual stakes i don't
really latch on to peter parker's
motivation in this film either someone
was trying to tell me that like this
whole problem is he doesn't feel like
he's good enough and he's trying to
aspire to be good enough and while i can
respect that
that
theme that this individual picked up on
for their fifth rewatch i did not
personally ever connect to that in the
film yes it's funny it's fine honestly
every time i watch it the first 20
minutes i'm like actually maybe i really
enjoyed this film but i really feel like
if it wasn't michael keaton in the role
i pro i wouldn't give two shits about
vulture i don't find him that
interesting of a character in the movie
and i really don't like how he seems to
get out of consequential situations with
exuberant amounts of help so the film
lacks a certain weight that i found
myself craving and especially after
watching mark webb and sam raimi's films
i find the action and cinematography to
just be nowhere near as interesting or
exciting in both films i do genuinely
love the relationship he has with ned
and i do believe what truly carries
these films is tom holland's exceptional
performance it's fine it's light-hearted
it's kid-friendly feels like the disney
fight version of spider-man my next one
i deliberated hard on and i could almost
interchange them really because what it
came down to me kind of is a level of
tedium given where i've started this
list i'm going to put spider-man 3 at
number 6 partly because i enjoy a lot of
that movie and for my own personal 100
personal purposes i might place it one
notch higher however this movie is if
you want to talk about odds with itself
i mean you can feel the studio problems
and it wildly oscillates between stuff
that you can tell sam raimi really cares
about and moments that are so like i
love one of my favorite moments across
all of cinematic spider-man is the
sandman formation sequence i think there
are some really great ideas in the movie
there are some really sweet touching
peter scenes i enjoy
unabashedly bully uh mcguire i think
that's like a a reasonable take on who
that guy would become if he was trying
to be cool it's got some of the most
dylan baker dr connors which i was
really looking forward to seeing there
is stuff that i genuinely enjoy however
there is also a lot that i enjoyed in
the past that then became tedious
characters that started to suffer or get
wackier and yeah it's the one i would
put on for more fun than say the next
one on my list but uh it's in a so bad
it's good kind of way or in a sort of
curiosity how did this go so wrong and
what could have been if it had gone the
way maybe the director intended to sort
of thing yeah i can't even get on board
for that first half hour when i'm like
why is peter so stupid i get it he goes
getting to his head like i get what
they're going for but i just cannot buy
just how insanely naive he would be
especially with kissing boring ass gwen
stacy in that movie yeah yeah
yeah there's some frustrating stuff in
the movie my number five would actually
be the amazing spider-man 2. if you
asked me a few months ago which one
would be at the very bottom of my list
it was actually the amazing spider-man
2. i had only seen it like one and a
half times when it first came out i
really didn't like it and as i feel like
time has gone on i i think the amazing
spider-man series just came out a little
too soon because i don't think people
were ready for just such a a reboot and
a shift so fast in style and tone an
amazing spider-man 2 while it tries to
do a little too much while i think the
green goblin thing was really
unnecessary for this film and and the in
the finale of it all how it kind of
undercuts the weight and the build-up of
electro i actually found that on my
re-watch i really enjoyed this film i
think it still advances the story of
peter parker for what they're doing here
they have some really great emotional
beats i like the scenes with dane dehaan
and andrew garfield everything with gwen
stacy and andrew garfield is freaking
phenomenal in this movie i think the
action is still really freaking good i
still think this swinging sequences are
awesome while rhino sucks yeah i know
the the rest of the movie i feel really
does still carry over the same themes
and weight and development and i
actually really like the time square
scene with electro i found myself
feeling really sorry for the guy in that
film and i actually like his portrayal
here more as wacky and as joel
schumachery as it is i really like the
intention of what they do with his setup
especially now did you like i could
totally see there's a guy like this that
exists in real world
to a certain extent maybe not his
cartoony but there's a version of this i
really find that all that is actually
quite impactful uh and i like more of it
than i don't like it like i think the
whole thing with peter's parents not
really necessary but i don't mind it too
much the death of gwen stacy is
beautifully captured it is there's a
reason why i feel like in no way home
when he saves mj that hits a million
times harder because that scene is
perfectly executed even in spite of the
fact of being like wise green goblin in
this movie yes yeah absolutely and hey
we reached our first instance of overlap
that's my number five as well and uh for
a lot of the same reasons there's a
level of tedium that this movie also
verges on but instead of being like
ultra saturated kind of chaotic
patchwork tedium it's more of a just
heaviness tedium i don't dislike uh
jamie foxx's max dylan i like the way he
threw himself into that character even
if i don't always love the way the movie
uses that character or puts music to
that character i do think the word uh
motif is a little funky um but yeah
there is a lot of like great dramatic
work and it does have more of a tonal
consistency than say spider-man 3 and it
still feels like it's authored by mark
webb even though it is a huge you know
money-making blockbuster it still feels
like it's continuing on a genuine vision
and it's part of the thing that sort of
helped me realize that spider-man in a
lot of ways is like the mcu the marvel
batman because it is the one that's
always an event when somebody gets to
reboot them or re-imagine them and
always brings along a certain film style
that's distinct and that's part of why
this does land higher than the other
ones is because it does still seem to
have a distinct voice at play even if
that voice is somewhat distorted or held
down by too much stuff going on number
four for me this one really shocked me
on my re-watch that it went down to four
is spider-man one with toby mcguire i
think for nostalgia purposes yeah at the
time it was like the perfect film that
needed to be as time has gone on as
comic book movies have evolved it's like
the way to really appreciate that movie
i feel and you might not agree with this
is to place yourself in the time when it
came out however looking at it for me
right now i do think they try doing way
too much i respect it in the sense that
it kind of moves at the pace of like a
graphic novel feels the most comic
bookie out of the sam raimi ones and it
moves at the pace of one but that also i
feel like kind of hinders the movie
where they do have like a gazillion
scenes in this movie and a lot of them
don't take the time to breathe or be a
little bit extra patient they're
covering so much time and they're doing
so much in the movie it's funny enough
as i feel like kirsten dunst her best
performance in the rainy films actually
spider-man 3. i think that's when she
does her absolute best in all three of
them in one and two i don't really like
mary jane okay and i don't really like
the acting of james franco and i'm not
even talking about james franco as a
human being
which is really questionable but just
his performance in these movies uh that
i don't really i don't really care for
that but i still place it higher than
others i listed is because this movie i
truly just think is a blast to watch i
absolutely love toby mcguire in it
despite some of the things i felt about
the pacing i thoroughly enjoy sam
raimi's whimsical comic style the danny
elfman score is beautiful rosemary
harris is excellent jk simmons as jay
jonah is beyond perfect casting and it's
got such an earnest campy spirit with
some truly gripping sequences plus
fulham the photo's green goblin is
insanely iconic and there's there's just
so much i do love that it outweighs the
things i don't enjoy as much anymore all
right uh number four i'm just gonna go
with what feels right and i'm gonna say
that that
is the amazing spider-man like i said
this list was really hard to compile
there are different reasons why i would
move these all across the board but this
was a big uh not surprise because i
remember enjoying it the first time
around but upon re-watch there was less
even that stood out to me as being you
know a gripe and yeah i really really
like andrew garfield's portrayal of the
character as well as uh emma stone as
gwen stacy like their chemistry is
unmatched i think across the spider-man
films and for that reason even now i'm
kind of regretting putting this to
number four but i'm already locked in
even thinking back i was like ah the
peter's parents stuff but i even like
that in this movie whereas in the second
movie it kind of starts to get to be too
much i i like the family environment
they draw around peter and the different
look that you get where yeah they are
struggling and there is dysfunction
between may and ben and peter and all
that and you do feel you know a lot of
the hurt at the core of spider-man while
the dr connor's story could certainly be
more fleshed out and more interesting a
lot some of the other you know villain
performances especially in the sam raimi
films i do think that that's a it's at
least pretty decent and risa fonz shows
up and i appreciated you know where the
story ultimately led everything with
captain stacy uh yeah i think it's a
really solid really good spider-man
movie i would say for my number three it
would have to be spider-man no way home
i've seen this movie three times now
it's good to watch it i think a few
times where you don't feel like you're
manipulated by crowd experience so you
really know how you feel about the film
because i was just going off crowd
experience building number one easily
well i think the last half is almost
near perfect for this one you guys have
heard us talk extensively about this
while i think tom holland is absolutely
his best portrayal he's ever done of
peter parker and this movie certainly
moves me to tears every single time i
watch it i think it's really just the
fact of the first half not all of it
just aspects of the villains i i we
talked about this more extensively in
our spoiler talk review i thought they
could have been a little bit more
interesting like while green goblin i
think completely out does what he does
in spider-man 1 there are aspects that
i've already talked extensively about
with the first half of this film that i
don't have an issue with the way it's
necessarily paced i really have more
issues with the way how some of it is
ultimately executed i didn't find like
the villain interaction to be all that
interesting amongst them almost every
time i watched them it was a bit of a
letdown like i really love green goblin
a lot i like doc ock because i like
alfred molina but like the portrayal
itself i'm not a huge fan of i actually
think jamie foxx is better than amazing
spider-man too and electro and like you
got all these villains and like the last
half i think is almost near perfect
while i love a lot of that first half
ultimately that's the only thing that
cause i love this movie that's the only
thing that edges it to number three and
while the other two are edging out like
literally this is more of a case of what
are the things that would make it a
little bit lower than one or two
yeah absolutely absolutely and also you
know how much do you factor in what came
before it because without those things
it wouldn't exist or work this was tough
and number three for me is also no way
home and i considered flopping it for
number four partly because let's get it
out of the way this movie took me back
to that feeling that is so rare as an
adult to have when you're at the
theaters of being like oh wow they're
doing something i didn't think i'd see
realized on screen that's beautiful and
and there are i think some moments a lot
of moments that really soar in terms of
emotional resonance and especially for
tom holland's spider-man it's easily the
best work he's done in that character
amongst already good work from him
specifically but yeah this made me
emotional multiple times it got me you
know cheering and hooping and hollering
like as an experience every time i've
seen it which is three times to this
point you know it's really swept me up
and and the only reason i really
deliberated on it is because in ways i
think it is kind of sloppy especially
with the villains and especially just
with the handling of the spell and a lot
of the sci-fi mystical mumbo jumbo a lot
of that does feel like mumbo jumbo and a
lot of it does feel like it's really
easy to poke holes and just ask these
weird questions about and i think that
is a fair point like i think the amazing
spider-man is a little more consistent
of a movie in that regard however uh
this has some of my favorite moments
from all three spider-man and it was
just so
gratifying to see that they put their
heart and they put their attention on
the most important aspects and they made
all those work and for that reason it's
number three for me you understand guys
usually i deep dive about all these
movies individually so we're trying to
sum this all up in like one minute of
why it's here on the list
comprehensive but quick number two for
me uh would have to be the amazing
spider-man before this was closer to the
bottom but upon re-watch i love this
movie i think it's absolutely excellent
you know
it's hard to make a realistic spider-man
movie because this is impossible just by
the nature of its character it's not
gonna be realistic for what they go for
it does feel like the closest to what
you can do with realism for portraying
peter parker i think andrew garfield
upon re-watching this i never thought i
would say this but he actually knocked
off toby maguire for me when doing the
re-watch of these films solely due to
the amazing spider-man because i think
he is so believable and so human in the
film and he does carry all this energy
and weird eccentricities but also brings
such gravitas as well and he feels just
like a real struggling dude and yeah him
and gwen stacy absolutely i actually
really love the action a lot in this
film while i think overall stylistically
sure sam raimi would have the edge on it
i think what they did here with it's
more of a of a gritty i don't think it's
as like grim as people used to paint it
to be while there's some grim moments
for sure i think like the way they
handle the relationships like with uncle
ben i think is so beautifully done aunt
may the final scene at the end was
giving the egg captain stacy in this
movie that scene at the dinner table
when you're realizing how this whole
time he's just on a revenge quest and he
doesn't really evolve into spider-man
until he has that he saves that kid on
the freeway uh when he gives him the
mask i'm like wow this is something so
beautiful and it's funny i really love
just how much this movie takes its time
it has a really nice gradual build and
pace i love how much of the scientist
side of peter parker is kept alive in
both this film and amazing spider-man 2
i really think the drama hits sometimes
hits really hard the whole experience
just feels very human i love that movie
i honestly i'm like yeah number two was
it was easy as hell for me to to figure
out and yeah this list was really easy
for me to put together good and in the
yang because every step of the way i was
like oh god i could put and so for me
number two again was a toughy i'm
basically splitting it
between uh brain and heart and going for
number two i would say is objectively
probably arguably the best spider-man
live-action adaptation it's spider-man
2. i can't really say a lot about why
it's not number one because yeah it's
terrific it's got some of the highest
emotional highs it realizes one of
spider-man's most iconic villains in doc
ock there are some incredible scenes
with rosemary harris's aunt may it's got
some of arguably
better you know
harry and mary jane stuff is okayish
overall that movie soars and and really
nails and realizes both just what the
live-action spider-man movie could be
and also it's one of the last times i
can imagine sam raimi helming a movie as
big and scopic and expensive and high
production value as that and it really
feeling like yeah this was his vision
this is a guy who's really charged up
about this material and yeah seeing the
growth of toby maguire's peter parker
and everything it's it's a terrific
movie and watching it again i was like
man this still has every cylinder i
remember firing firing a hundred percent
yeah i mean obviously number one is
still spider-man 2 for me that hasn't
been edged off i really think that every
obviously everything that you said but i
think this film beautifully captures
the the whole thing about you know peter
parker and the main struggle that he has
which is how to be peter parker and be
spider-man yeah and this movie i think
excellently does that i think this is
easily toby mcguire's best performance
out of the sam raimi trilogy his
subtlety and comedic moments with just
like
expressions he can do a lot with a
little while i do think on the re-watch
i was like okay he kind of doesn't have
his powers for a little too long in this
movie
it goes on a while
when it gets to that the build up of
when he does get his powers back and
goes to fight doc ock nothing is more
pulsating to me than that like that is
such a gripping moment i feel like every
single shot in spider-man 2 is so
goddamn composed everything is so
freaking thought out whereas i felt a
little bit more like sam raimi
spider-man one moved a little bit like a
comic book this one moved a little bit
more like a film meets a graphic novel
yeah in terms of the way it's aesthetic
was done and while i still don't really
care for mary jane in the movie i do
find the last bits uh pretty
heartwarming and endearing with them it
really does feel like cinema to me
especially uh yeah i love i love the
hell out of spider-man 2. and i would
still personally place the whole second
fight with doc ock leading to the whole
train sequence to be the best fight
scene in comic book movies from all the
emotions it evokes to the camera works
staging and choreography it was on a hot
minute where i was like does making
spider-man 1 take it for me but not it'd
definitely still be spider-man 2. well
then that just leaves number one for me
which is yeah the original spider-man
and i again never got better than that i
mean no i i think spiderman 2 is the
superior film and especially the
marriage of digital and practical
effects for doc ock is is incredible but
when i you know just waved my sort of
heart meter over every slot in this list
the moments that are the most ingrained
to me i kept thinking of these moments
and i was like damn so many of the most
iconic spider-man motion picture moments
to me come from the original spider-man
and yeah it is absolutely a personal
choice a nostalgia choice yeah in a
sense yeah and just watching it again i
still for some reason for me i still
emotionally pang and resonate with that
iteration of peter a heck of a lot like
i feel myself quite you know sort of uh
i don't know affected or harmonizing in
a way when i watch that and seeing the
early stages the budding stages as he's
trying to kind of talk to mary jane and
as they're still learning how to
communicate with each other he's
learning his powers he's changing you
know everything with uh you know going
after uncle ben's killer and everything
just there's so much in that movie that
resonates a lot still i like the comic
book pacing and the comic book coloring
and everything like yeah it does feel
more comic booky or like it rests on
that more than say spider-man 2. but i
really appreciate that i like all the
fun flourishes with randy savage and
bruce campbell and all that norman
osborne's green goblin still is iconic
in my mind as is doc ock but yeah just
there's something about his portrayal of
that villain that presence left such an
impression on me then and i think is
still really compelling now and also
then has that really great payoff in no
way home whereas you know doc ock kind
of continues and helps out but it's not
as you know emotionally you know fist
punching is that so for various reasons
it's still my favorite i like the comic
book pace but at the same time i was
like
maybe slow it down a little bit
it's fair i think it also too really
hits that sense of discovery and and
wonder uh oh yeah yeah there's an
argument that you know yeah i still like
the film a lot yeah all right guys well
what is your ranking tell us why greg is
wrong in the comments so why john is 100
right as always guys subscribe click
that bell hit that like button and hey
we will catch you all soon